four months after the devastating
bombings sri lanka is still looking for
answers but there's little help from the
prime minister
he said his security personnel had no
knowledge of any warnings they didn't
get to know at all I questioned them
they have no such information Vikram
Singh has the most senior member of the
government to appear before the
Parliament Select Committee
investigating the Easter bombings
coordinated suicide bombers struck three
churches and three 5-star hotels on
Easter Sunday killing more than 250
people and leaving hundreds more injured
a local extremist group supporting ISIL
was blamed investigators uncovered plans
to carry out further attacks
after weeks of testimony from law
enforcement defense and political
representatives one thing has become
clear a catalogue of serious
intelligence failings combined with
rivalry between agencies resulted in one
of the country's worst terrorist attacks
but more disturbing was the fallout
between the country's president and
prime minister the pair have been at
loggerheads since the president tried to
get rid of the premiere in October 2018
and failed relationship has not been as
cordial it was before and this is why I
thought that this matter should be
investigated by a parliamentary
committee president metropolis Arizona
has repeatedly denied receiving
intelligence warnings of the impending
attacks he has slammed the Select
Committee sessions as an attempt to
blame him anti-muslim violence broke out
a few days after the attack many
observers saw the violence as the work
of organized groups today a reminder
that things are still volatile a
Catholic statue in katoa padilla scene
of one of the April 21st bombings were
stoned tensions flared Muslim shops were
closed and the head of the Catholic
Church appealed for calm a heavy
security presence was needed to restore
normalcy the incident a stark reminder
that the scars of the East
means will take time to heal Meena
Fernandez al Jazeera Colombo